they want us to subtract these two
numbers and simplify the answer and
write as a mixed number we're going to
do it two ways the first way we're going
to turn both of these into improper
fractions and see what we get and then
the other way we're going to keep we're
going to subtract the whole number of
parts and then subtract the fraction
parts and see what we get so if we turn
them both into improper fractions let's
first turn eight and two-thirds into an
improper fraction so it has three in the
denominator and three times 8 is 24 24
plus 2 is 26 so 8 and 2/3 is the same
thing as 26 over 3 and 5 and 5/6 so
we're going to subtract we're going to
have 6 in the denominator 6 times 5 is
30 30 plus 5 is 35
so this simplify or as an improper
fraction is 35 over 6 now to subtract we
have to have a common denominator 3 & 6
are not the same denominator but they
are both divisible into 6 6 is the least
common multiple of 3 & 6 so let's turn
them both into something over 6 so the
26 over 3 if we put it over 6 to go from
3 to 6 in the denominator we have to
multiply by 2 so we have to do the same
thing in the numerator we have to
multiply 2 times 26 which is 52 so it's
going to be 52 over 6 minus minus we
don't have to change this one here in
orange it's already over 6 minus 35 over
6 which is going to be equal to what's
52 minus 35 let's see if you add 5 to 35
you get 240 15 will get you to 15 will
get you to 50 and so we want two more so
it's going to be 17 so it's 17 17 over 6
this is as an improper fraction now if
we want to write it as a mixed number we
say how many times the 6 go into 17 well
6 times 2 is 12 so that works 6 times 3
is too big it's 18 so it goes in 2 times
now if you get take it into it 2 times
you get 12 and then you have 5 left over
right to go from 12 to 17 you need 5 so
you have 5 left over you could say 6
goes into 17 2 times remainder 5 so 17
over 6 is 2 & 5 6 & Weerd
done now this is kind of the improper
fraction route which you'll it'll always
work it'll always work sometimes it's
easier harder but it will always work
actually either route will always work
but I tend to do it this way
but let's do it let's do it separating
out the whole number and the fractional
parts so first we could view this as 8
minus 5 so let's do this 8 minus 5
that's subtracting the whole number
parts plus 2/3 2/3 minus minus 5/6
now 8 minus 5 that's easy that's 3 and
then over here though we have an
interesting well let's try to work it
out if we try to do so plus let me do
this in a different color we want a
common denominator here and we already
saw that 6 is the least common multiple
of 3 & 6 so we could write them both
with 6 as a denominator 5 6 already has
6 in the denominator we don't have to do
anything there to go from 3 to 6 in the
denominator here we have to multiply by
2 so let's do the same thing with this 2
2 times 2 is 4 so this results in 4 6
minus 5/6 which will give us and we
haven't covered it yet a negative number
if you take 5 from 4 you're going to go
below zero now if we don't want to deal
with that negative number what we could
do and this is essentially you know the
same idea as regrouping or borrowing
although it shouldn't call it borrowing
they should call it taking is we can
rewrite this 3 that's why this can get a
little bit tricky sometimes we can let
me do it over here let me draw a line
here so we don't get the two ways of
doing the problem confused we can
rewrite the 3 as 2 plus 1 but instead of
writing as 1 we could write it as 6 over
6 right 6 over 6 is 1 plus 2 is 3 and
then if we add it to these guys so plus
4 over 6 minus 5 over 6 now what
happened by doing that well if we throw
this 6 over 6 into the mix and then we
add 2 4 over 6 and then we subtract the
5 from it then we're going to have a
positive number so let's do it so we get
we get this 2 right here so it's 2 plus
and then over 6
over 6 we have 6 plus 4 let me write it
6 plus 4 minus 5
now what's this going to equal this is
going to be this - this - and what over
6 and over 6 6 plus 4 is 10 minus 5 is 5
so you have 2 & 5 6 which is exactly
what we got the other way